Matthias: Hello I'm Matthias Lüfkens from
the World Economic forums media team and responsible
for social media activities.
I'm here at the Davos debate corner with Reem
Kassis who brought you all the presidents
and prime ministers and royals to this edition
of the Davos debate.
The annual meeting of the World Economic forum
is finished, and we would like to thank the
entire YouTube team who helped us set up this
amazing experiment. I'll start off their names.
Thanks to Steve, thanks to Jeff, Lee, Olivia,
Reem: Tom
Matthias: Tom, Rashna, and Robert and I'm
sure I'm forgetting a couple.
A big thank you to Julia [Inaudible] who won
the Davos debates this year.
She brought her cause, the fight against female
genital mutilation to Davos.
Her panel that was here yesterday is up on
this channel, you must watch it.
It is amazing how she starts her cause and
reignites her cause.
Absolutely brilliant, you should watch them.
The Davos debates are not finished, they will
continue in all our regional events.
This year we will be in Vietnam, in Morocco,
we will be in Tanzania Africa. We will be
in India and in China.
So hoping to continue this discussion with
you, thank you very much for all your questions
and videos and signing off from Davos.